J'adore cette période de l'année.
Quand les arbres sont en fleurs
et que les feuilles commencent à éclore.
C'est un poirier. Elles sont toutes petites mais déjà
le théâtre d'un phénomène extraordinaire.
À l'instant où je vous parle,
les cellules qui composent la feuille
captent le dioxyde de carbone
qui se trouve dans l'atmosphère.
Au même moment, les racines puisent de l'eau
et des sels minéraux dans le sol.
Tous ces éléments remontent dans la feuille
jusqu'aux cellules qui vont utiliser la lumière du soleil
pour découper ces molécules et ré-agencer les atomes sous forme de sucres qui vont nourrir la plante.
Voilà pourquoi on parle de "photosynthèse".
Ça fait du bien un peu de soleil
dans une "capsule de déconfiné".
Allez, à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés, mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour. Alors pour
ne rater aucune de ces "capsules de déconfiné",
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain !